I keep seeing a bunch of comments
claiming that people have to be
absolutely out of their mind to buy an
intel-based Mac right now since Apple
announced that they're switching to
their own arm-based Macs
but that's simply not true these words
from Apple's Greg Joswiak prove it we
are also trying to get people used to
the idea that you know Intel systems
took a bit around for a lot of time
right we're gonna continue releasing
versions of Mac OS for years to come
to support our intel-based Macs and we
still as as Tim said we still got some
intel-based Macs to introduce now you
might be wondering what does years to
come mean well here's your answer how
many years are years to come for support
for Intel Macs in Mac OS years years I
believe the words we used obviously we
got a lot of customers on Intel based
system so you know we're pretty good at
taking care of our customers you know
that so if you think about it basically
every Mac out there right now uses an
Intel chip so apple has to support them
for the same amount of years as they
currently do and if you take a look at
which Mac's currently support Mac OS big
sir even Mac's made seven years ago
still supported so if you buy an Intel
based Mac right now you should expect it
to run the latest Mac OS software for
the next six or seven years before they
will finally be a new Mac OS version
that only runs on an apple chip and then
at that point your Mac will still
continue working on the older version of
Mac OS until you decide to upgrade it so
apart from that there are a few very
good reasons why it actually makes more
sense to buy an Intel based Mac but of
course there are still some people who
would be much happier with an ARM based
Mac and I'll discuss those reasons right
after I cover the benefits of buying an
Intel based Mac but first I want to
mention that we have our new premium
Apple product hoodie available right
below in the merch shelf and let me tell
you guys this thing is incredibly soft
and comfortable one of the major
benefits to an Intel based Mac is boot
camp support it has already been
confirmed that our Mac's will no longer
support Windows
ten using boot camp and that is a very
big deal not only for the people who
want to play games but also for people
who need to use productivity apps that
are only available on Windows there are
a ton of people who purchased an eg PU
set up for their MacBook so they could
play games in Windows and that will no
longer be possible using our Macs
now Apple did mention that Windows 10
would still be able to run on these new
Macs but using virtualization software
like parallels but the gaming
performance is horrible dan the sound
man showed off the new parallels 15
which finally supports Direct X 11 and
basically every game he tried out was
unplayable since you're trying to run
Windows and all of its drivers using a
virtual machine with in Mac OS gaming on
Windows will die with our Macs
so that's why it totally makes sense to
buy an Intel based Mac right now and
enjoy Windows 10 on it for the next six
to seven years you can either use an e
GPU or you can buy the new 16 inch
MacBook Pro with the new 5600 M graphics
option and get even more FPS than with
the most popular 5700 x te GPU and we
even proved it in this video which I'll
link to at the end of this one an even
bigger deal for a wider range of
customers is that the transition to arm
is going to be a bit bumpy for the first
couple of years there are a lot of Mac
users who need to use third-party apps
and plugins to get their work done and
this requires developers to recompile
their apps to work with apples chips
alongside Intel chips and there's a very
good chance that when our Mac's start
coming to the market some apps that you
use won't be updated at all to work with
arm now Apple does have a solution for
that and it's rosetta - which emulates
Intel based apps on the fly to work on
arm chips the main downside with that is
that the apps will obviously run slower
with Rosetta - then if the app was
actually recompiled to work with arm and
one thing to keep in mind is that even
the apps that will get updated in
we'll also need to be realized which is
a process that sometimes takes
developers months or even years to
finally get right so there's a very good
chance that if you switch to an ARM
based Mac that might even be more
powerful than your current Intel based
Mac your apps will probably run slower
for at least a year or two while
developers get around to updating and
completely re optimizing their apps for
arm and there are people and companies
who need their Mac's to run quickly to
get their work done because they
actually make money with their machines
so it makes sense for people like that
to buy the upcoming intel-based Macs and
hold off on arm until they know they'll
get better performance with the apps
that they use and speaking of those
upcoming intel-based Mac's which we
should expect Apple to release very soon
they should be some of the most powerful
Mac's we've seen in years
thanks to Intel finally putting out
their tension chips and AMD coming out
with incredibly powerful Navi graphics
which leakers have discovered support
for in Mac OS big sirs source code
that's exactly what we expect for the
upcoming into based iMac and just
earlier today a new Geekbench 5 result
was leaked showing an Intel based Mac
with a 10 core eye 9 processor and an
AMD Navi 5300 graphics card running on
an apple motherboard both of which have
never been seen before in a Mac so
realistically it makes a ton of sense to
buy an Intel Mac instead of waiting for
arm enjoy great performance for all of
your third-party apps and enjoy all of
the features like Windows 10 using boot
camp and then in two or three years when
arm-based Mac's finally proved
themselves
you can then make the switch and sell
your Intel based Mac to someone who
really wants to use boot camp and now
let's discuss the market of people who
are base Macs really makes sense for
right now if you don't really do much
work using high-end third-party apps the
transition to arm is going to be super
smooth for you since Apple's apps will
run perfectly fine on day one and on top
of that arm Mac books are most likely
going to have substantially better
battery-life then current-gen MacBooks
and right now the current MacBook Air
suffers from overheating issues and high
fan noise when using even common apps
like zoom video conferencing the ARM
chips will run much cooler and have less
fan noise for common tasks and we know
this for sure since the current a12 Z
Apple ARM chip and the iPad pro is
completely fanless and it stays
relatively cool even while gaming
another upside to waiting for an ARM
based Mac is the fact that iOS and iPad
OS apps are gonna run natively on these
new Macs so games like pub G and Call of
Duty mobile will run on your Mac finally
and all you need to do to get an
excellent gaming experience is hook up a
controller and the final reason is that
Apple could surprise everyone with
incredibly powerful arm chips right out
of the get go current rumors are
pointing to a 12 core 5 nanometer ARM
processor coming to the first ARM based
Mac this year which has four more
high-performance cores than the seven
nanometer Apple developer transition kit
that they're sending to developers right
now and if we look at the benchmark
performance of that machine in Geekbench
5 which is also running Rosetta to
emulation and not fully supported by arm
that upcoming 12th core 5 nanometer ARM
chip has the potential to outperform the
current 16 inch MacBook Pro right out of
the gate that means if you use Apple's
apps like Final Cut Pro Xcode and Logic
Pro 10 there's a chance that these are
based Mac's will perform better than the
intel-based Macs because Apple will make
sure that those apps are optimized in
advance but we'll just have to wait and
see so basically the point of this video
is that there is a large market of
people who will actually be better off
buying an Intel based Mac right now
especially due to the fact that Apple
has confirmed that they'll continue
releasing software updates for Intel max
for years to come
so hopefully you learn something new
from this video and if you did be sure
to check the links down below for the
best deals on the current intel-based
Macs right now and be sure to tap the
like button below and click the circle
above to subscribe for more videos like
this one and
make sure to check out our new hoodie
right below thanks for watching and
we'll see you in the next one
[Music]